the cast of empire got together as part
of a big celebration for the Fox hit now
when the first half of the season ended
things were a little crazy in the lions
world so we went to the party looking
for some secrets before the show returns
on the 30th Gareth I see you guys are
talking who me yeah this is how you get
Empire news get the cast together and
pry those secrets loose what we do off
set
first thing we do we hug each other then
the moment somebody walk away we talk
taraji P Henson was off in Atlanta
shooting a movie so Terrence took over
the PaleyFest panel that I got to host
meanwhile on the red carpet we set to
rest the rumor that Trey Byers is
leaving the show I'd love being here I
don't know how many times I can say it I
love being here rumors of Trey leaving
were fueled after his pregnant TV wife
Rhonda was pushed down the stairs
well somebody dies I'm gonna tease that
and you know you don't know who takes
over Empire in this exclusive look at
the mid-season premiere lucious wages
war for control of Empire entertainment
in a pathetic don't you think lucious
you think this is some kind of game get
out of my office